there's a winter storm here in the
Northeast with hitting Philadelphia
Washington DC New York and Massachusetts
and Jim Cantore of course is right in
the middle of things and Jim the star of
The Weather Channel joins us now Jim
where are you right now we're in Newbury
mass mr. Patrick now Remax why did you
pick Millberry minutes we needed to
leave Boston because I they're gonna
change over to rain and you know my love
of deep deep snow I had to get in it so
it's gonna be here not there how bad is
this going to get well I mean I think
it's actually been pretty good for the
for the i-95 corridor because what
started out two days ago as what looked
like about 18 to 24 inches in some of
these spots the low has definitely
shifted to the west all the model trends
have been like that now we're looking at
you know basically a saline storm in New
York City will see some snow first for
Providence and Boston and they'll change
over to rain as well so that part of the
interstate I think will be just fine but
that said like you know where I am in
Worcester County mass central mass the
Litchfield Hills of Connecticut
Berkshires upstate New York
Northeast PA probably double-digit
totals over 20 inches in spots do people
ever get mad at you if you've under soul
or oversold something well think about
how the Atlanta Falcons fans felt after
the Superbowl sometimes I get a little
bit of that well what do you mean that
was the most that was awful that was an
awful loss are you kidding me I mean
they expected them to win I mean you
know they're up you know 17 points we
got you know the game in the bag or
strategy involved at this point just run
out the clock no no what I get when I
get these people get 18 to 24 inches and
all of a sudden they wind up with a
three inch 4 inch lead storm there's a
little bit of that too ok I mean but but
it's not like I didn't achieve the call
mother nature's didn't live up to what
we expected
that's kind of rough oh no no you're
shifting the blame you're better than
that Jim thanks Ann you're all hard
buddies what's the definition of lizard
lizard' 1/4 mile visibility or less
winds 35 miles an hour or greater for
three consecutive hours or for several
hours with in the event the the ice
portion of this though is always the the
tough one to two handicap here we know
about snow can prepare for snow but with
the ice portion of this it's different
those lead is better because freezing
rain freezes on everything where the
surface is below 32 degrees in this case
these are like little sleep balls that
are dropping and they can plug it can be
plowed you can actually get some
traction on them so it's a little it's a
little different element so the freezing
rain with this probably isn't going to
be a big big issue I think it's gonna be
more sleet snow or rain has the crew on
the Weather Channel ever had a snowball
fight we have on air we have we had a
good one
not on air again come on really like we
like to promote like a unity it seemed a
team building kind of thing and doing
that on air might might involve hurting
somebody let's put the Abrams and I have
tackled each other in the field though
so that's McKenith oh yeah so yeah we
have a little action is the show have a
fun little roll in the snow is the snow
too deep for you to do push-ups
never never could you do that don't know
what you're doing to me right now with
the Massachusetts State Police just
walked up to our vehicle and they're
there wondering what we're doing here on
the side of the road so so even the
Weather Channel has a tough time getting
respect sometimes could you do push-ups
on the air for us you know what we do
the next day so I'll be at see that's
til 11:30 so at 11:00 I'm gonna promote
that you give me the exact 10:30 10:30
10:30 okay so 10:30 so five minutes from
now six minutes yeah okay then all how
many how many do we how many how many
inches of snow did you say was going to
happen
15:15 here all right 15 push-ups 4
inches of snow all right all right I
appreciate that as always been saved you
you got it bro thank you it's Jim
Cantore The Weather Channel moments from
now doing 15 push-ups live on the
Weather Channel the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience